but what's wrong with that especially if
you're in high school like let me just
make my point let me flip back to you
kindergarten elementary school even
middle school stay the f away from the
freaking kids you're 16 years old you're
able to drive you have a car you have a
driver's license you're confused about
what you got going on you're already
making out with guys girls you're
already maybe even having sex i got no
problem in high school no problem that's
me totally adam's different in a way no
children
okay
so what does that mean you have no
problem with what in high school
with 16 18 year old kids having
conversations with guidance counselors i
don't care go in your little safe room i
don't care about that
if you if you think what how old are
your if you're girls
10 and 16. okay so let's move the 10
year old aside to the category of don't
f with her but 16 year old 17 year old
18 year old if you think her and her
friends aren't already having these
discussions you're naive so i'm just
letting you know in high school that's
what's already happening what do you
think about that tom i
i have a fantastic relationship with my
16 year old daughter and we process
things all the time because that's
exactly what she wants to talk to her
dad about she actually by the way on
this scenario
i will tell you in this case it is true
i believe you know i know because i
thought seeing this i'm not even talking
about biz doc here i'm talking your
point is what you're doing the 18 year
olds in general these are conversations
that they're already having and tom
you're saying what you're saying to the
teacher you're saying to not have the
conversation for for teachers to not
have the conversation with students
no
absolutely not i don't want a teacher
bringing their views
on my child period
now if they go in there and say hey i'm
really bothered about something these
kids are cheating i don't want to be
part of it um i don't they're in my
friend group and i don't want to get
pulled into that those conversations
happen all the time at school all the
time
i don't want to get in the middle of
this but i don't want to be a rat i
don't want to be a snitch things like
this happen all the time but the deeper
things i mean you know what happened i
told you and sure going course no no i
get it
because i don't want that girl to
accidentally be exposed um and bailey
came and talked to me about really bad
decision that a friend made
really bad decision her parents were
very concerned about it there's a lot of
things that go along with it but we
processed it like what was she thinking
where was she now here's the thing tom
to be fair
you can afford to put your kids through
a good private school go to public okay
go to
95 of america whatever the percentage is
that's got their kids in private public
school because of a zip code they're
only making 55 000 of your median income
say household is 100 000 right and
they're facing those parents are facing
a war that's what they're facing now and
that's what i'm talking about by the way
if tom who's very well off can send both
of his kids to private and by the way
tom kids are fantastic shout out to kim
however
that's not the representative of what's
going on in america i taught i taught in
school i taught second grade i talked
eighth grade in miami i know what 9th
10th 11th 12th like they're already
doing stuff so if you want to live in a
fantasy world that like of course my
young daughter is going to come and talk
to me about and process issues that's
great in fantasyland and private school
that's not the reality for most of
america but i still think even in a
public school a guidance counselor if
you're under the age of 18 and you're
having these serious conversations with
somebody and opening up the parents
should be involved and that is i think
what we're talking about here is that
there's a fine line with what the role
is of the teacher to an underaged person
if you want to make the decisions after
you're 18 if you love whoever you want
to love that's fine i don't think we're
taught
from my understanding we're not talking
about that we're talking about the
younger kids who are in school and this
is being pushed on by the culture and by
their teacher totally agreed k through
eight don't even mess with the kids but
at a certain point like so talk about
seniors in high school are you saying if
if
if a sophomore
uh is confused and goes to the guidance
counselor saying hey
uh mrs johnson
i'm i'm really wondering with all these
pronouns i'm really wondering what i am
i'm really struggling with that what do
you think i'm having a hard time talking
to my mom and dad about it because i
know if i talk to my mom and dad about
it they're going to get really upset
what do you think's the right choice for
me to make well number one i any
question they have whether if you could
be a straight guy and just be like look
man like i'm i'm dealing with some
bodily stuff that's happening right now
i don't feel comfortable talking to my
mom about my boner that's just kind of
weird and i'm gonna go talk to my
guidance counselor i'm okay with that
should talk to your guidance counseling
about your boner that's i'm just saying
like this is the reality
if we want to just like sugarcoat
everything and we learn a little bit
much about adam today i'm just saying
this is what 16 year old mr jones hey
what i'd like to talk to you about
but but go to but i'm actually sometimes
yes
if the kid is what should um here's the
question yeah let me know by the way
these aren't just teachers this is a
civics
let me be more specific so if
the 14 year old adam is concerned about
it 14 not 14 high 16 in high school yes
well 14 i was in i was in high school at
14. ninth grade high school fourteen i
was a fourteen-year-old in high school
i'm telling you i'm telling you i
graduated 17 years old in high school
not because of a great brother well you
were also breastfed you were 18. that's
your point so but go to 16 years old
stay at 16 years yes 16 years old you're
in 11th grade you're driving a car i get
you you go to your guidance counselor
and you say listen my name is adam i'm
kind of confused right now what are you
i was never confused
but you go to your guidance counselor
and you say you're confused
having problems with my girlfriend what
should no no no no no this is not
problems with your girlfriend this is
the the we're talking him and her and
pronouncing something lgbt we're
specifically on this topic here okay how
should the guidance counsel handle that
i'm afraid of talking to my dad because
he's gonna lose it he's a traditional
jewish man or you know he's a
traditional
hispanic whatever you know so i come
from a christian family how should what
should the guidance counselor do i'm not
going to pretend that i know the answer
of what the guidance counselor should
say or not say here's what i will say
yeah i'm okay with them having a
conversation like the fact that they're
conversing and talking and they're
saying i've got questions like that's
the guidance counselor's job to have
guidance i don't disagree i don't think
i disagree all i'm asking is what should
the approach be from their end because
that's the training that's got to come
from this as a parent do you want them
to just go right back to the parent hey
by the way little timmy had questions
about whether he's gay or not do you
think he should make you aware would you
want to know that as a parent or no if
i'm a parent of course i would want to
know that maybe doesn't want to share
that but i call you as a guidance
counselor and i say hey adam i got a
question for you can i share something
with your son i think you need to know
about but he it's very important for you
and i to build a relationship together
because if you go and automatically tell
them what i told you i think you're
gonna lose i'm gonna lose trust and i'm
not he's not gonna have a person to go
to can i trust that we can build this
relationship together you and i yes i
think you ought to have a conversation
with your son because he's struggling
without that dot do you think that
conversation should be at or do you
think the secret should be between the
guidance counselor and the kid that's a
very valid question i mean it's like
where where do you draw the line what
what would you want me to do forget
forget what the valid question is you
want to have kids one day what what
would you want no no no no no if no hear
me out no hear me out hear me
hear me out don't
i don't care what the kid says okay say
the kid says don't tell my i don't give
a [ __ ] if the kid says don't tell my
parents
if the kid your kid comes and tells me
the guidance counselor don't tell my
parents okay
how do you want me do you as a parent
still want to know or you don't want to
know
obviously if i'm a parent i would like
that's the point i would like to know
okay but if the kid specifically says
like for instance i had an issue with my
father growing up right he was a very
abusive guy if i went to my guide this
is a totally separate topic but but this
is actually a good point
but if i said hey look i'm having a
problem in my house my father's very
aggressive very abusive
it's a thing that i'm dealing with i'm
coming to you to talk to you through
these issues as tom says to process
these issues would you do me a favor not
tell my dad that i came to you to tell
you about this if the guidance caller
picked up the phone and called my
parents and said by the way adam just
came in and he's telling me about the
right move for him for the guidance
counselor to do that but that's but like
this is what i'm saying a 16 year old is
not a 10 year old wait a minute it's not
a four-year-old
the ability to or from
and the guidance counselor's purpose is
to get cps child protective services
involved so that we can protect the
nation's youth when you do have a parent
out of control we're talking not about
that you move the argument i don't think
that's intellectually honest adam but
thompson i said this was something i was
dealing with i i didn't move the i
didn't move the goal post i said this
was something that still
stick to him and her that's funny stick
to the him and her if a kid goes to this
teacher 16 years old guidance counselor
saying i'm wondering what i am sexually
i don't want to bring it up to my debt
because i think he's going to lose it
can you please help me out with this
should that guidance counselor call the
data on the mom
no no
really not at 16. got it really no what
and um
what do you think so the reaction is
just so then why even have a yeah of
course that's my opinion just like it's
your opinion that's the whole point
everyone here has an opinion so whatever
you say
is a parent
i actually want to do this let me do
this and then i'm going to come to you
and i'm going to hear your thoughts as
well okay so explain to me why
again is it is it because you want your
kid to have a
place where they can talk that they're
more comfortable than the parents
is that why or is it a place to release
rather than hanging on to themselves
okay let's start with the reason that
they're going to the guidance counselor
it's because they probably don't feel
comfortable bringing it up to their
parents okay let's just start with that
sure like okay i have an issue hmm
i can talk to my friends about it but i
don't want to be judged i could talk to
my parents about it but i'm certainly
gonna get judged for whatever i'm gonna
have to say it's not exactly the most
comfortable conversation with your mom
and dad about sex
okay i don't care how good you are at
processing issues i'm not trying to talk
to my mom and dad about
bodily sex stuff facts
so if this is a person who is a
qualified
professional and this is their freaking
job yeah i'd feel okay closing the door
and saying hey can i talk to you about
such and such and such if god forbid
my kid for example if they i don't have
a kid but in the future
if that led to a mental health problem
down the line because they were
struggling with this and they either
wanted to take their life or had or
struggling with something greater that
guidance counselor should be telling the
parents because it can turn into a
broader mental health conversation that
doesn't
that it's the parents job to be involved
with their child
once you're 18 fine whatever
but for that particular case i also have
a big issue if these guidance counselors
are looking at things objectively and
they're actually being professionals and
and doing their training and talking to
these kids that's a different story but
if there are guidance counselors that
are pushing this as well that's a bigger
issue is that it's all a cultural
problem i think
if the guy i mean look as far
let's not
villainize teachers we're not we're okay
we're not trying to teachers have the
hardest jobs your wife's a teacher
my mother was a teacher okay i was a
teacher my mom was a teacher but
teachers have a very tough job they're
overworked and underpaid they are and
let's not villainize teachers that
they're all trying to like reverse lgbt
all our kids i'm not sometimes they need
to have crucial conversations look at
the schools
that would tell you otherwise how so
go to a public school in a
democrat-leaning state and what you see
there
is is pretty concerning what the kids
are being just in democrat leading
states so republicans are perfect
from illinois so i don't live i don't go
to schools here in florida but in
illinois if you go to those schools and
you talk to kids and what they say that
their teachers are doing is it very
concerning
if if every teacher is the teacher
what the teachers are doing is very
concerning that's what she's saying but
continue if
guidance counsel i all i said was if the
guidance counselor is able to look at
these things objectively that's a
different story if teachers are able to
look at these problems objectively
instead of pushing their own political
ideologies that is different but what
the the culture is showing us is that
they are pushing their ideology and that
is a problem i love teachers the
teachers that want to teach are great
and they should be
they should be elevated but the others
particularly the millennials are not
doing that half the time that's the
problem do you have any other angle from
what we talk about here with adam you
you're the only one in the room here
that's got a 16 year old daughter
well
he just told me i had an opinion before
he heard what i was going to say because
it's back with facts
so it's not my opinion i'm just going
back on on facts there's a simple simple
fact it is a fact in these democrat
leaning and hard blue districts the
guidance counselors and the teachers are
actually denigrating the position of the
parent you should come talk to us we see
people like you every day i see 50
students your parents sees one you we
know what's going on we know what's
going on you should come talk to us
so that's what's happening it's not
what you just said oh i can't talk to my
dad my friends are a little confused
i'll go talk to my guidance counselor
there may be a threat of that adam but
they are being absolutely encouraged to
come talk to the guidance counselors and
the teachers that are presenting them
this other viewpoint and i'll
tell you this we need to go dig up tyler
go dig up the stats on teenage suicide
and it and
sexual orientation confusion kids are
writing these suicide notes out
talking about confusion talking about
they don't know talking about these
things and and so you want the guidance
counselor to talk to your kid
and then
your kid commits suicide and you never
knew
and you never knew well the discussion
fair point so there shouldn't be until
they're 18 adam you're responsible for
them until they're 18. they break a
window down the street technically you
got to pay for the window you're
responsible for them until they're 18.
what a point what did you hear what a
power that was a very good point because
anything they screw up with is on me so
i may as well know about what they're up
to because if they do screw up it's me
being liable for it that's a very good
point by the way two people just gave
super chats uh fifty dollars above
azul said adam these thoughts increase
risk of suicide significantly while
parents are responsible we need to know
especially
if there's another adult involved and
potentially influencing then tico
gave 199 adam is clearly adam is clearly
wants those communities to grow even
more but if it if medium movies and
social media is killing next generation
making people stay in comfort zone lazy
and easily upset emotionally but here
here's what i'll say zoel is right yeah
is that yeah here's what i was saying
when it comes down to this if there is
an area that's extremely think about
think about areas that you everybody is
sensitive in certain things everybody
the other day we were doing a conference
call and one of the leaders asked me a
question and then she asked how do you
deal with sensitive people okay
i said what do you mean well how do you
deal with people that are sensitive i
said everybody's sensitive
you're sensitive i'm sensitive
don't get it twisted that just because
you
are not sensitive in an area that i'm
sensitive in as if you are not sensitive
in any area you have certain
sensitivities but it's going to be
different than tyler's title is going to
be different than times tom's going to
be different than a catalinas the point
when it comes down to kids that is a
very
very very sensitive area because
anything you pay the biggest price for
anything you build a business you busted
your ass for 10 years working 80 hours a
week let me let me
break it down for you that person that
runs that business extremely sensitive
about protecting the business right kids
you spend all those hours that's a lot
of sensitivity so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]
you